we're going to jump into the story from
jody so we can better understand exactly
what's going on with your case
and what you're experiencing these
universities so all laid out i think
most people
understand wokeness critical theory
which is not just race theory it's also
critical gender theory
there's they seem to be formless in a
sense like the rules don't really make
sense
they just want you to bend the knee and
adhere to their strange subjective
reality
it's resulting in overtly bigoted and
racist policies which in my opinion
violate the 1964 civil rights act so for
me personally
one of the reasons i supported trump in
this election cycle this past election
cycle
was because of his because of his
executive order banning critical race
theory
in the government as well as contracts
with companies that do this
because i've seen firsthand what happens
when you implement
these neo-racist neo-segregationist
policies
universities are creating affinity
groups they're telling all the white
people to segregate all the black people
to segregate
and then it creates very strange
problems with whether or not asians are
minorities or they're white and
privileged
so you've experienced this first hand
and first
just tell me the story and and whatever
detail you want to tell us a story
where you ultimately resigned from your
job because i guess they were being
racist to you for being white
yes that's accurate all right thank you
for telling your story
what happened where did you work smith
college what's going on smith college so
uh
i started off as smith as a temporary
librarian working in the library as an
outreach and engagement librarian and i
was hired
to do you know kind of out-of-the-box
things to engage
students who otherwise normally wouldn't
engage very deeply with the library
and um about
i don't know almost a year after i was
hired i was or six months after i was
hired i was tasked with a
doing a wild and crazy event for 600
first-year students
and i decided and i was given a big
venue
and the people who gave me the venue
said we will give you this venue if you
do something wild and crazy because
these kids are going to be exhausted
this is the sixth day of the event
um so you gotta agree to that so i did
and i thought
and i'm i have a musician background so
i thought well what's the best way to
transmit a bunch of very boring
information
to a bunch of six six hundred 600
first-year students
obviously a wrap so everyone knew i was
going to be doing a wrap i spent months
preparing working with musicians getting
everything set up the sound and
everything and simultaneously i was up
for a permanent job at smith college
so i worked all summer on this and then
something happened at smith
on july 31st 2018
a student a black student accused a
white
custodian of engaging in racially
motivated behavior
against her she was in a house that she
was not supposed to be in it was over
the summer
and the staff there had allowed her to
be in the house but this custodian
didn't know who she was she was lying
down in this living room
couldn't see her very well and this
document this incident's been
documented quite well now in a recent
new york times article
ever since that incident um the college
immediately
so the student that was like two years
ago wasn't it yeah this is in 2018
july she made a facebook post so she
didn't even file a formal complaint
she simply posted about the experience
on facebook and said that this was a
just another example of a pattern of
systemic racism she had experienced at
smith college
so smith the college immediately sprung
into action um
announcing profuse apologies to the
student and to the student body
and announced its intention to launch
all these initiatives and
committees and conversations and discuss
dialogues
to combat this issue of systemic racism
at the college and this was before
they'd even
conducted any investigation into what
had actually happened that day
so they did conduct an investigation a
very thorough one and they found that
there was
absolutely no evidence of racial bias
and anyone who has
is privy to the facts of what happened
that day and has read this
investigatory report which is it's 35
pages plus 130 pages of exhibits i mean
it was really thorough
they would be hard-pressed to argue that
this was an incident of racial bias
that in and of itself is insane that a
woman was sitting down
in some she was in a closed door a
janitor saw her and said who's this
so instead of confronting the person
which could have been a bad call he
called a cop
the cop was very polite this video of it
where he's just like how's it going how
are things
sorry for bothering you and that
warranted an independent investigatory
body coming in
a 35-page report 35-page report plus
exhibits floor plans audio recordings
they
investigated phone calls to campus this
is campus police so unarmed
it wasn't like the town police this is
campus police a 30 a guy who'd been
working there for 35 years
his name is robert young beloved
spotless
record um he showed up and he actually
i think he recognized the student i
heard he recognized her and
and and she was able to stay um
so yeah they really it was like they
were really trying hard
to almost to prove that it was in my
opinion almost to prove that it was and
and they weren't able to that
the outside investigators said this this
is not an incident of racial bias
and yet they proceeded with all these
initiatives
and it's almost like it didn't matter
what the event was they
wanted the the anti-racism which is just
a name by the way they wanted the
critical race theory
policies in the school and it sounds
like they knew it was bunk but they
needed a pretext
and even though it was proven bunk they
moved forward anyway
that's i think that's an accurate
analysis
um so so what ended up happening to you
then so what happened to me was you know
meanwhile i'm in the library working on
my rap
and um about so this happened on july
31st and
the the orientation i was doing was
happening in very early like right after
labor day and so within a week
of me doing this huge thing organizing
an event for 600 people
it's no small undertaking i was told my
supervisor came in and said you know you
can't do this you can't do a wrap
and i said why not he said because
you're white and it would be seen as
cultural appropriation
so um did you try identifying as not
white
i i did ask i said i said that's kidding
i didn't i said
i said so if i was not white or
i know i said if i was a person of color
and i didn't indicate what color
i said if i was a person of color would
i be allowed to do it he said yes
without hesitation so obviously just
anybody except for somebody who's white
what about eminem
did you tell him that yeah well when he
did it white supremacist dude prolific
actors of our time
yeah seriously uh rappers of our time
right now i'm kidding by the way
well i mean yeah people say that
mclemore and i mean of course tom
mcdonald but
i mean really rap is is an american
it's an american art it's an america
it's culturally american i
i think that's my view i don't
understand why we all can't just
you know appreciate you know what i mean
like it's actually like racist of me to
try and play that game about what about
a white guy who did it too and was it
right it's an american art form
who invented the guitar where did the
guitar come from huh good question
who's using that or keyboards or
turntables
who invented the record player yeah or
the loot uh
everybody everyone that's that's why i'm
like this stuff's really scary because
it's it's kind of obvious let me ask you
the the the supervisor who came and said
you can't rap
is this like a middle-aged white dude
he's a white dude but he's not
middle-aged he's younger than me and
he's actually the head of the search
committee for the job i was up for so it
was very awkward oh
was he woke like
i mean he's toeing the line so coward
he's it i'm you should don't don't
answer that don't answer that
uh i personally do not respect
individuals who would say something like
that because
i think what he said to you was was
extremely racist
extremely right it was so it was but it
was so unhesitating
i mean the manner in which he said it
and then followed up by email he
memorialized this in an
email in writing and then i went to the
dean of the libraries and i said you
know
what's going on and she actually told me
to me something that was a veiled threat
remember i was up for a job and she said
well
how you choose how you manage to be
resilient in the face of this situation
is really going to give us a lot of
information in light of your candidacy
for this job
it was something like that i'm
paraphrasing so i mean that's to me
that's a failed threat
and so the fact that they did it
so blatantly and explicitly i was
genuinely confused um i was like because
when i heard about the student
all i heard was a black student was just
lying on a couch in a house
and somebody called the police on her
that's terrible like that was the
narrative that i heard
you know i had didn't really go because
there was no investigation
that's what the college told me i really
didn't have reason not to believe them
at that point
so i was confused i was like well you
know this really feels like racial
discrimination he literally told me
because i'm because you're white you
can't do this
this op job opportunity um and
i wrestled with well should i file a
complaint i was like but
can white people be discriminated
against like is that possible and i
thought well gee if i
if i report it i'll never get a job here
because white people aren't supposed to
complain about this stuff they're not
supposed to do that and so it was a very
um hard hard for me emotionally to
wrestle with
what i was supposed to do with that
and what i ended up doing was i ended up
leaving the library
and moving to a different department on
campus thinking that i could get away
from because there was also
lots of these discussions and dialogues
discussions dialogues that were
happening even before this
event had occurred that i just went
along with and again i had no reason to
believe oh there's systemic racism okay
and i guess you know as a white person
you're supposed to talk about
your privilege and that's going to help
somehow so i thought
okay but inside it always felt like
it felt kind of um disingenuous so
you didn't quit at this point no i left
i stayed in the school yeah it's a long
story so i went to a different
department
and i didn't know that this department
the department of residence life
is very steeped in this the social
justice
um that's one of its like core values
and again at the time i thought oh
social justice yeah
i'm i can get with that i hadn't quite
put all the pieces
together and i think this is part of the
problem is a lot of people are genuinely
confused you need to be watching tim
cast irl
it's not your fault though i mean you
know a lot of people don't know about
how awesome i'm kidding i'm kidding
continue continue
yeah i definitely need to be watching
tim castle
[Laughter]
so uh yeah i moved into this department
and
other things started happening on campus
like the campus police officer who
showed up to that
incident was was terminated a year later
and this is a guy
for racism no it's for undisclosed
reasons wow
and he was a 35-year veteran about to
retire
spotless police right he was beloved we
called him officer bob he was there when
i was a student there
that's that's a simpsons joke where
they're like he was two days away from
retirement
like they do that all the time like the
dog gets hit by a car like oh it was two
days away from retirement
here's this cop i mean it's it's it's
kind of
it it's it's it's parody and of itself
it's like life imitating art it's so
it's so absurd yeah it's absurd and it's
really it's tragic
um because the other thing that happened
with this student was she made this
facebook post and then she made
a subs she didn't know the name of the
custodian she couldn't identify the
custodian who had called campus police
on her so she posted the photos
and email addresses of two other wow
unrelated like people who were not
involved um a dining room person and
another custodian who wasn't even
there he'd left to shift for the day
before it even happened
and those two the lives of those two
people were
i mean i think it was catastrophic one
of them
uh during the investigation he was put
on leave and
a paid leave and he ended up not coming
back to the college he had pre
some pre-existing conditions and it was
it was too much he didn't come back and
then
the dining room worker uh was harassed
i mean she got phone calls she got notes
in her home mailbox
she students would whisper and point at
her there's the racist
she recent she was then furloughed this
past summer
and she applied for a job somewhere and
the you know to to make up for the fir
for the loss of her contemporary loss of
her job at smith
and the person who are hiring her said
weren't you the person
that was involved with that student when
the they called the police and she was
like no no she tried to explain and she
she didn't get the job
i mean we can't know for sure that well
she didn't get the job for that reason
but i i would say yes but i what you
understand
once the word gets out you'll hear this
look i understand you weren't at fault
but i mean we
we can't have those people coming after
us so i'm just sorry you understand
right
yeah that's the thing once you're out
there you are unhirable
and it's not when it's not about whether
they believe you or not it's that they
don't want you near
there so now so so now you're waking up
to the realities that are the
the cult of you know wokeness
but you still work at the college i
still work at the college i'm starting
to wake up i'm starting to like pay
attention more
um some other things start happening
around campus i feel like i'm walking on
eggshells
i'm trying you know i took a lower
paying position
as um in admit doing administrative
support so i was no longer a teaching
librarian i was kind of like i thought
oh i can hide down here
that's kind of what i thought very nuts
and bolts like getting students their
ids getting them keys
very very like salt like practical kind
of job
and yet you know i was told i had to
attend
uh staff meetings where people were
talking about identity
um we talked we had there was one staff
meeting where we talked about
the cl how colonialism
was it white supremacy
like examples of how white supremacy
still manifests at the college
and one of my colleagues started banging
on the table saying rich white women
rich white women and
he was talking about the alums he was
talking about the alums
and so nobody batted an eyelash you know
i'm like this
feels very like i mean this doesn't feel
professional
there there was no like did they start
bang bang on the table and chanting
google gobble one of us at you
trying to convince you to join the cult
didn't happen is that
anybody who gets that reference you
deserve something a president what is it
i don't actually it's from uh thank you
it's from the movie called freaks
i think i think it's called freaks and
there's this beautiful woman
she's trying to marry this freak who's
got an inheritance and so all the freaks
at the table are
chanting google gobble one of us but
she's not a freak and so she's like no
and she like runs away screaming yeah
yeah that was me
i'm that woman so but but is that how
you ended up quitting or
no so then like you know i started
gently i felt gently talking to my
supervisors like
because the other thing they were asking
me to do was to support a curriculum for
students
that was essentially telling students
that you can break the world down into
two groups of people oppressed
and oppressors and oppressors are white
and everyone else is oppressed
and i felt like that was really such a
disservice to students it made me very
uncomfortable it felt like
the infantilization i was talking to
lydia about earlier of
of students like telling students of
color like you can't quite handle the
world and
until until your white counterparts
start talking about their white
privilege
nothing's going to happen for you it's
kind of this toxic dependency
thing and i i just felt like it was
incredibly disempowering to both
white students and non-white students
and so i tried to raise this several
times with my supervisor
nothing happened i finally just was like
i'm not i don't want to talk about my
race at work i started thinking gee you
know you can't ask about race in a job
interview
so how is it that this is a continued
condition of my employment
um so i was told we were going to go
this is the big event we were going to
go to
a professional development retreat on
campus and the first day we would be
discussing our identities
so i went to my supervisor and i said
you know and i knew that meant race
because that's usually what it means and
i said you know i'm uncomfortable
discussing my race at work
and she said no problem just say that at
the
retreat so i thought okay so i went to
the retreat and everyone went around the
table and we did the script
talking about our race and it was
actually they wanted us to talk about
our race in the context of our childhood
no less race culture they were like
conflating the two
and so i said i'm uncomfortable talking
about this at work
and then a little later one of the hired
facilitators said
i was the only one to abstain by the way
one of the hired facilitators said
you know any white person who
declines or exhibits discomfort which i
had
um in discussing their race when
requested is not actually uncomfortable
you might want to
you might want to feel like you empathy
for them but don't they're actually
doing it what they're doing is a power
play
and it's called white fragility and so
they said this and my
my heart just dropped because this was
in front of all my colleagues
and that's when a line was crossed for
me
because i realized this wasn't just i
couldn't just keep
you can't just keep your head down and
mouth shut in this environment this is
an environment in which
now shame and public humiliation is
being used as a
tool to compel certain behavior
because they wanted me to talk about my
race and i they wanted me to talk about
in a certain way
i answered the question authentically
which is i am uncomfortable
discussing my race and that was not an
acceptable response
so at that point i knew i had to file a
complaint
which brings me to filing the complaint
with the officer in charge of making
sure smith follow
complies with eeoc which is the equal
employment opportunity commission
laws she has a jd and when i went to
file my complaint
i met with her and she looked at me she
was rather incredulous
and she said do you believe in white
privilege
and i was like what and then she said
you know the civil rights act of 1964
was created to protect
traditionally marginalized groups of
people so i interpret that to me not me
and then the last thing she said was
you know i'm going to have to hire an
outside investigator to
to deal with this if you're going to
proceed with filing a complaint of
racial discrimination and harassment
and i said well why is that aren't you
the person that processes these
complaints and she said yes but
this is different because you're white
she literally said those words she
literally said those words she said that
twice
two two different occasions and i
followed them up with emails of course
um because by now i'm i'm being very
careful about
paper trail and everything so when so i
i filed the complaint and i filed it i
think it was probably like a week before
george floyd was murdered
and so smith
smith went into hyper drive after the
july 31 2018 incident with the
combating systemic racism stuff and the
all the initiatives they went into super
duper hyperdrive
after george floyd and and remember this
time like we're in a global pandemic
nobody knows what's going on suddenly
everybody's like the college is closed
everyone's working from home we're going
to furlough all these people everyone's
worried about their job
and the college comes out with this
four-page document called toward racial
justice smith outlining
further initiatives including
initiatives aimed at
measuring uh pay across registers of
identity
so we're talking about like you now it's
being tied to your job performance
so at that point i started sending
emails to hr and other people asking you
know can you give me definitions
of this stuff like what do you mean by
equity and what does this mean because
now you're telling me this is tied to my
pay
and they there was
nothing happening in the meantime i was
getting invited to
white staff only meetings and
um being told that letters from the
president saying white people are
especially responsible for combating
racism and doing this work and we all
have to work and do this hard work and
it felt like it was just constant
constant emails
and constantly talking about what being
white
and how responsible white people are for
all this racism and how horrible the
systemic racism is
and um and how i need to do all this
work
and by now it's been made clear to me
that it's not optional right i mean
they say well you know it's optional but
if i don't go i've been you know it's
like
clearly that could be interpreted as an
act of aggression or a power play
so um cut to october i finally
decided that i was in a bad state
psychologically and and physically and i
decided that my
my health was the damage that i was
causing to myself by remaining in this
environment
was worse than what might happen if i
made a video about it
so i made a youtube video and that
actually kind of just
blew up i didn't know what would happen
did you quit at this point
no you really want to get to the part
where i quit
no yeah kind of i guess but not really
i'm just curious if like you know
it sounds like i'll put it this way it
really does sound like you you you were
constantly being pushed to your breaking
point
and from what you're telling me you're
like they told me i had to say this and
i'm like wow surely that made you quit
but hearing that each and every beat in
the story you're like
you stayed through it i tried yeah
because i i was going through
all the internal channels of trying i i
had i was a good faith effort on my part
i thought well
surely if i show them that this
is wrong surely they will
be like oh maybe we should review our
policies or oh gee this is hurting
a staff member is coming us telling us
this is hostile and she's being hurt
like
surely we should listen to this person i
i just have i have
i no longer have faith in smith college
but i i still had some faith at the time
that perhaps
and i also knew i should i needed to
exhaust my internal
remedies too um so i made some videos
and i got put under investigation like
within a month
for an unrelated thing and
um then i was they found me not guilty
of whatever it was i was under
investigation for a slap on the wrist do
you know what the investigation was for
yeah um we had received after i made the
video we received a bunch of emails to
my department
the departmental email which i respond
to a bunch of people respond to it and
it was like you know
uh jody shaw's a white supremacist she
went on talk because i want to talk to
carlson after i made the video
um she's associated with a white
supremacist
therefore you should fire her and so i
was forwarding these emails to my
personal account because i'm documenting
everything by now and um
they said one of one of those emails
contained student information
i'm not clear on what they didn't tell
me which email was
um and i wasn't able to determine which
email they meant
but it was a slapped on the wrist and
then it was like
uh okay um you can come back to work and
i i
it felt like that was a hard choice um
whether or not to go back or um
i'm not going to talk about the there
were some
settlement negotiations which i won't
get into but um
i it felt like going back into an
abusive relationship
and i thought i wouldn't go back into an
abusive relationship so
i can't i can't go back and that's when
i resigned
i can't believe you made it that far i
can't either thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you